[Musique]
à votre avis d'où je viens
non plus
alors ça fait partie de la France
mais ce n'est pas en France
d'après vous d'où je viens
de l'Hexagone
[Musique]
c'est une région dans le sud de la
France
oui d'où je viens de France non
ça commence par quelle lettre R
République
[Musique]
c'est à côté de l'Australie
c'est une mine qui se situe à côté de
l'Australie et qui est française
et bien je suis né en Nouvelle-Calédonie
[Musique]
dans cet établissement il m'est arrivé
une fois de régler un différent ou un
élève avait été appelé arabe par un
autre camarade il s'agissait de deux
enfants martiniquais et après on s'est
attaché
à montrer à celui qui avait employé
cette expression que ça n'avait pas de
sens que quel que soit l'origine dans le
pays Martinique il est formé d'élèves
d'origine syrienne d'origine européenne
d'origine africaine
moi mais ma maman
elle vient comme moi elle vient de
Toulouse aussi et mon papa il vient de
Martinique mon père vient de Toulouse et
ma maman vient de
Suisse mon papa il est il vient de
Martinique ma maman elle vient de
Guadeloupe mon grand-père sa grand-mère
a été en Inde et ma mamie
c'est en Afrique
du côté de mon papa
il habite ici et il a des origines je
crois que sa mère elle était indienne
les sociétés sont multiples et elles se
connaissent donc on peut ressembler à un
africain mais l'Afrique c'est un
continent extraordinaire donc j'ai envie
de dire qu'il faut apprendre à vivre
avec son originalité son entité propre
et chacun d'entre vous vous avez votre
originalité
donc il faut savoir l'affirmer il faut
en être fier et si vous êtes dans cette
démarche les autres vont vous accepter
on est tous différents on ne vit pas au
même endroit
on retrouve le même ciel les mêmes
nuages les mêmes soleil la nature et les
animaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a vraiment des livres qui sont
longs
bah c'est comme moi moi je lis que des
petits livres oui c'est pas intéressant
vous êtes d'accord joli peu de livres
mais en fait tout dépend du livre que
j'ai en face de moi par exemple
si on me donne un gros livre avec
beaucoup trop de pages et qui n'ont pas
de mal ça ne m'intéresse ça ne me motive
pas c'était au CP je me souviens j'avais
ma maîtresse la première chose qu'elle
nous a fait le jour de la rentrée elle
nous a lu une histoire et je me souviens
que cette histoire en fait m'avait
marqué et depuis j'ai toujours eu un
livre quelque chose dès que je
m'ennuyais j'avais un livre dans la main
et c'était surtout pour moi un peu je
pouvais m'échapper si je m'ennuyais si
j'avais des problèmes c'est comme c'est
un peu mon jardin secret ou alors des
amis que je viens voir souvent
j'aime bien cet aspect de la lecture qui
nous permet d'imaginer ce qu'on dit
d'imaginer un autre monde avec une face
plie
c'est mon frère qui m'a donné envie de
regarder manga alors ce que j'étais
petit je devais avoir 8 ans je voyais
souvent lire regarder les mangas du coup
à un moment j'ai décidé d'essayer et ça
m'a passionné
qui a plus d'intérêt que le livre chez
beaucoup de jeunes pourquoi parce que
c'est un mode d'écriture qui leur
correspond peut-être plus qui est
moderne
elle me dit ça aussi
c'est nul c'est pas intéressant
j'ai envie de leur dire qu'ils sont
ignorants la plupart des gens qui me
disent ça sur les personnes âgées ou qui
ont plus de 40 ans ou 30 ans il pense
souvent que mangas sont inutiles que
c'est ça sert à rien mais en vérité il
se trompe il y a des mangas très
intelligents très charismatiques qui
nous parle de choses dures et profondes
ou alors de choses simples aussi la
société la politique la notion de bien
et de mal quand on voit ces personnes
sont totalement ignorantes
autant on a des clients ils vont acheter
de la littérature autant beaucoup de BD
de mangas vraiment c'est très diversifié
mais la lecture en littérature reste la
même
[Applaudissements]
parce que ça me faisait rêver
maintenant j'aime plus les images parce
que j'imagine que deux choses Mathéo
j'aimerais entendre ton avis
c'est pas que j'aime pas lire mais dans
sa propre route
on sait quand est-ce que ça va se finir
il y a une durée parce que le livre on
va stimuler lentement bah ça va prendre
du temps si tu lis pas lentement
enfin c'est compliqué
on arrive facilement à rentrer dans
laquelle on arrive à se transporter
on va dire que quand j'ai besoin de me
reposer un peu je lis parce que ça me
permet d'avoir une autre vision sur le
monde c'est vraiment ce qui me passionne
l'histoire le fond ou alors un message
il veut cacher derrière que j'aime bien
par exemple certaines histoires d'amour
qui peuvent dramatiques ou alors qu'ils
peuvent se passer bien ou c'est un livre
qui peuvent redonner goût à la vie par
exemple ou même parfois des fictions qui
nous font voyager ou qui nous animent
quelque part d'autre qui ouvre une autre
porte à notre imagination
mes histoires préférées ce sont les
histoires qui parlent d'esclavage parce
que ça touche vraiment beaucoup de
personnes ça ça fait partie de notre
histoire et aussi les histoires des
violences faites aux femmes et du savon
j'aime bien ces histoires là parce que
c'est magnifique le combat que les gens
meuniers pour
réussir à avoir une certaine liberté
aujourd'hui
j'aime particulièrement ce livre qui se
nomme Simon l'enfant du XXème qu'on voit
parce que il parle déjà comme je l'avais
dit de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et il
est basé sur une histoire réelle donc
tout en racontant une histoire et me
permet de d'apprendre beaucoup plus sur
la déportation des Juifs donc il me
parlait de connaitre d'apporter nos
connaissances sur le sujet lire un livre
ça permet de s'évader ça permet
d'imaginer une histoire ça nous apprend
aussi beaucoup de choses alors je dirais
aux jeunes de choisir un livre pas
forcément un gros lit mais un livre sur
un sujet qui est intéressant et je
verront que c'est pas mortel que voilà
ça leur permet de de comme s'il
regardait un film et ça serait vraiment
bien
[Applaudissements]
tu vois c'est pas si mal les gros livres
intéressantes
[Applaudissements]
et les enfants particuliers c'est issu
d'un film je connais le film cela mes
préférés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]